resilience
the house is separated into a number of
zones including residential household
safety and the production of food and
energy and each needs to be durable
enough to be sustained alongside each
other that's why the walls of the house
are built from reinforced monolithic
concrete and steel featuring the
futuristic angular design distinctive to
the tesla cyber truck this means that
the house consists of several rings or
defensive reinforcements each acting in
contingency with one another so if one
is breached the others remain one
noteworthy feature of the cyber truck is
its monocoque chassis design meaning
that the body and the chassis of the
truck are considered as a single unit
this design feature creates a cage-like
shell to the body of the truck adding
major resilience and improved safety to
the vehicle this cage-like reinforcement
is reflected in the steel-clad exterior
design of the cyber house
the ground plan
the ground plan for the post-apocalyptic
shelter is 7 500 square feet or 700
meters overall and boasts an impressive
3230 square feet or 300 square meters of
living space making it a roomy setting
to wait out whatever crisis is raging on
the outside the plan for the futuristic
cyber house puts the building into three
distinct floors each with their own
designated purpose to help see you
through the apocalypse the first of
these floors is the one you will enter
through at ground level driving your
cyber truck through the garage entrance
you leave the vehicle in park where an
inbuilt elevator system will take it out
of sight and underground to allow you to
make the most of your living space the
two adjoining wings function as the main
living quarters of the house over the
west wing of the ground floor are a
series of bedrooms three to be precise
each of the bedrooms can sleep two
people and they feature their own
self-contained toilet unit on the
opposite wing of the ground floor two
further bedrooms are situated both also
containing their own bathroom units as
these bedrooms are also designed to
comfortably sleep two people the eastern
wing of the building brings a number of
people designed to inhabit a cyber house
to a grand total of 10 also featured on
the ground floor of the cyber house is a
communal bathroom and a disinfection
shower unit in the event that some
catastrophic event were to cause high
radiation or toxicity the inhabitants of
the cyber house can avail of this
chemical shower unit to protect
themselves against radiation poisoning
at the far end of the east wing on the
ground floor is a lounge area so you can
sit back and relax while zombies plague
the earth outside on the opposite side
of the building in the west wing
dwellers of the cyber house will find
their kitchen and dining area equipped
for 6 to 10 people so everyone can enjoy
cooking up the produce grown on the
terrace of the house underneath this
main residential area is the bunker
floor the bunker level contains a series
of reinforced rooms which act as stock
rooms in which the essential supplies
needed to keep dwellers alive are kept
inside these store rooms would be foods
preserved through drying freezing and
canning all of which would need to be
brought in from the outside several of
these store rooms are necessary in order
to stock enough food to see six to ten
people survive a prolonged period of
staying in the bunker and the cyber
house is designed to stockpile several
months worth of food should someone be
injured or need medical attention the
cyber house needs to also come stocked
with its own set of medical supplies
that can be put into use in an emergency
while the food supply rooms are being
stocked with tins and cans the medical
supply rooms of the cyber house would
need to be stacked with medicines pills
surgical equipment and medical
apparatuses such as defibrillators and
ventilators this kind of worst case
scenario preparation is key to the
survivalist attitude that the architects
of the cyber house feel is necessary to
make it through the apocalypse so the
food stockpile takes care of the fuel
the dwellers will need to make it
through the day but the cyber house
itself is also in need of a source of
fuel that's where the bunker's generator
rooms come into play the subterranean
bunker houses a series of generator
rooms designed to make sure that the
shelter can continue to support life
even in the event of a cut-off from the
main power supplies bunker houses a
state-of-the-art security room that
monitors the exterior and interior of
the building cameras sensors and alarms
are all part of the high security
precautions built into the cyber house
all activity captured on this system can
be monitored and responded to from the
security control room in the house's
northeast corner of the bunker using the
built-in elevator system in the core of
the cyber house dwellers can make their
way up to the convertible terrace floor
that sits on the top of the futuristic
abode the rooftop terrace is designed to
be a comfortable yet highly functional
center of productivity for the entire
household in any apocalyptic scenario
self-sufficiency becomes a major factor
in the chances of survival and the
terrace is where the cyber house makes
self-sufficiency its biggest priority
atop the roof there is the possibility
to grow a wide variety of plants and
herbs that can be used to feed the
members of the household beyond
providing energy for the humans living
in the house the terrace is also
designed to function as the power
generator for all the house's mechanical
operations the roof is decked out in
tesla solar panels each of which
possesses a 340 watt output given the
size of the cyber house having the
entire rooftop covered in these panels
means basically having a personal solar
farm to keep everything running smoothly
additionally the cyber house designers
have suggested secondary power
generation in the form of a set of
windmills hooked up to the house with
the ability to generate power from
whatever storm might be raging outside
the price tag
estimates on the cost of one of these
futuristic mega homes vary wildly
depending on the exact specifications
and amenities desired by the buyer the
designers say that the house itself
could be constructed for as little as
865 000
although this doesn't take into account
the huge cost of equipping the house
with all the necessary gadgets to make
it the post-apocalyptic sanctuary it's
intended to be the solar panels windmill
medical accoutrements and high-tech
security gear would naturally drive the
price up considerably but given that the
house is designed to withstand
everything from natural disasters like
hurricanes earthquakes tornadoes and
eruptions to technogenic accidents like
chemical emissions and radioactive
contamination the high price tag might
just be worth it and as elon musk's
philosophy is centered on long-term
thinking and sustainability we wouldn't
be surprised if he was interested in
matching the cyber truck to one of these
cyber homes
[Music]